we took the decision not to oppose his
transfer to another hospital
the one that his relatives indicated to
us
that was what navalny's wife yulia had
been desperate to hear
she had been fighting since arriving at
the hospital on thursday
first to get her husband's own doctor to
see him
then to get the german medics in
we believe that the doctors are
deliberately delaying so that the
chemical substance in my husband
alexei's metabolism
has time to disappear that's why they
won't let him leave the hospital
alexa's health situation is probably
very bad so we don't believe the doctors
in this hospital
and we demand that they hand my husband
over
he'll come here the charity hospital in
berlin
two years ago its medic successfully
treated another russian dissident who
seemed to have been poisoned
that was [ __ ] riot activist piotr
versilov
the group who'd flown versilov out sent
medics to go get navalny
and persuade the russians to let him fly
for more let's bring in professor sergey
guryev former chief economist
at the ebrd that's a european bank for
reconstruction and development
he's also one of the top sponsors of
navalny's anti-corruption fund
and is a close friend navalny arrived
today professor in berlin for treatment
you must be feeling relieved
it is a feeling of relief but as you
rightly said
the situation is not out of the woods
yet he's unconscious
and in the best case scenario we
probably should expect that it will take
several
weeks to nurture him back to health
and indeed as you refer to the case of
pyotr verzilov
it was a very difficult and painful
recovery
all of this is clearly sensitive stuff
um
but to the extent that you can talk
about this who do you think
might be behind this apparent assault on
navalny
and we do not know and we do not know
why it has happened still i would uh say
it is very important to remember it's
not the first
attack on navarro using chemical agents
uh
he was attacked in 2017. the video
cameras actually identified the men
who executed the attack this man was not
investigated interrogated or prosecuted
the second time he was attacked last
summer uh when he was detained
in the moscow prison and the attack was
actually administered
within the prison within the prison cell
so it was also very easy to investigate
it was not investigated as well
which kind of tells you how the kremlin
treats people who attack nabarni
and even if it's not ordered from the
very top of course it's the very top of
russian government russian
russian authorities that is responsible
for
attacking navalny this time one thing
which i would like to
remind you you mentioned regional
elections there will be regional
elections
coming up in three weeks from now
navalny has developed a
highly effective strategy for opposing
the ruling party in those elections
it happened last year the last year was
extremely
uh important breakthrough in various
regional elections including in moscow
that's why nobody spent so much time in
jail last year
and apparently government was very
nervous regarding the election that is
coming up
navalny was still is
a very effective communicator his
youtube channel his weekly youtube show
is watched by millions of people and of
course government didn't want him to be
on
air in the coming weeks until this
election
professor what can you tell us uh about
his current condition
what have you learned i
don't know anything except for what is
what is being reported and and uh
this is uh what you've just covered in
your piece and uh
we we just know that he's unconscious
and we don't know what exactly caused
uh his uh coma you mentioned uh just uh
before
that there were two attempts on his life
uh that were never investigated
is it your belief given the
international attention to this
particular story and others like it
that that is going to change
i don't expect in this particular
situation i don't expect that as long as
this regime is in power in russia
this uh crime will be investigated i i
have no doubt
that this poisoning was administered
using special forces usually using
special
chemical agents uh not dissimilar to
those that you've mentioned in the case
of pyotr withdrawal for other russian
dissidents including
vladimir karamurzakh who was actually
poisoned twice and of course
the attack in salisbury where one
british woman died
in russia it is still denied that russia
was behind the salisbury
poisoning and in that sense in that
sense i think that as long as this
regime is ruling russia we shouldn't
expect
a transparent investigation you yourself
do not live in russia do you believe
navalny will return
after this latest incident
it is a question for alexey navalny i
know him for many years
he alexey navalny that i know is a brave
and courageous man and he believes that
he will come back and i i cannot decide
uh for him it's for him and his family
to
make this decision but everything i know
about alexey
the fact that he's been attacked before
and still continued his very important
work
i would think that he will actually come
back he will not stop his fight
professor sergey guryev in france thank
you so much for your insights
thank you very much dw's uh julia
saodali has been reporting on the
arrival of alexei nalvani
at the charity hospital in berlin there
she caught up with jacob bazil
founder of the cinema for peace
foundation which paid for
the airlift she asked him about
navalny's current
health conditions well we're very happy
that he finally arrived in berlin that
we could fly him out
[Music]
the good news is that he's stable
so the whole travel did not affect him
but this doesn't mean that i mean
obviously we're kind of like
very happy everybody's happy but there's
no reason to celebrate
because he's still in very critical
condition so the real work starts now
with the doctors at the charity
did the german government have any role
in assisting or
helping with the operation to bring him
to berlin we're very happy to hear two
days ago
that angela merkel together with the
french president made a statement
that it should be found out what
happened and that
if he needs medical assistance he's
welcome in germany and france and other
countries offered too
so i think this was very helpful and
obviously um
we kept the authorities informed about
our activities
but these activities were private and
what does the family feel and think at
the moment and what do they
expect going forward with his taking
care of at the hospital
well i think they're relieved that the
siberian odyssey has ended
the relief to be in a first-class
hospital to have a good treatment
and obviously now it will be the
question what the doctors can do and
have to do
and i mean apparently
this is not a thing for a few days it's
been probably a long procedure
and it's a long way to go i mean as we
as we've heard from the doctors
if there would have not been this
emergency landing in omsk if they would
have tried to fly on to moscow he would
have died
thank you very much
you